- She got a lucky one.
She gonna go home, get lucky.
- X-rated, cut that out.
- [Woman] Dumplings.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, nice to meet you.
My name's Lily Yang and I am from Taiwan.
So I'm gonna show you how to make Chinese
dumpling Taiwan style.
Okay, let's get started.
So usually I marinate with
the soy sauce and not much,
because we got to put some salt,
so you don't want too much soy sauce,
add some white pepper,
and then put a little bit ginger in there.
Ginger is good for the body.
When you have a cold, as
my grandmother would say,
take away your cold.
So then you wanna set this aside.
For 10, 15 minutes,
and then you wanna drop your
green chopped vegetables,
about two-thirds of the meat
and one-third of the vegetable,
and then just kind of mix
together.
- First time I see anyone
using bok choy in the dumpling.
- Oh, the first time for me too.
But I never, never see anybody do that.
- I usually don't use the Chinese cabbage
because too much water.
You blow the dumpling skin.
And then I put some wine in there
just to make it taste good.
So what you do is,
because it is a machine make skin,
so you need to use
water to dip on the side
so you would stick it together.
So when we were a kid, they
can wrap all kind of shape.
But my grandmother always
make like Chinese money.
It's nice, right?
- The way she's folding it,
it's so cute.
- Perfect.
- And then you put the
almond in the center.
You can hide it, this is
like secret ingredient.
You don't wanna tell anybody.
So the lucky person, that's
just going to have the almond
in the center.
And when they bite it, it's crunchy.
- I wish my husband would do that
and put a diamond ring in it.
- Oh my gosh.
- So I'm ready to put in the boiled water.
You can just slowly pull it in there.
Okay. And then you wanna make
sure you stir a little bit.
You don't want them stuck
in the bottom and then
I just pour another cup of water.
And then I just put the cover.
When the dumpling is ready,
they will float on top.
And meanwhile I can just mix the sauce.
Soy sauce and then I
have a little sesame oil,
put a little wine there
just for the taste.
Some people like a lot
of wine so they can get
a little buzz.
Okay, and then I have to
put little chive in there
and then garlic and ginger.
And then I usually put a little jalapeno,
actually this is not
Chinese, just for the taste.
That's your dipping sauce.
So they all blow up like this.
Okay, when they look like little bubbles.
So meanwhile I just put some oil,
because if you don't finish it right away,
they stick it together.
The thing about my shape,
you can even stand up.
Look at that!
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- My name is XiaoZhe Liu, I
came from mainland of China
called Shenyang, it's Northeast.
First of all, I'm gonna soak a spice.
Gets rid for the fishy
smell from the meat.
Spice, green onion, and ginger,
and I'm gonna put hot water inside.
Any grandma make dumpling,
they can make pork dumpling.
But lamb is difficult.
You got to cook perfect.
Otherwise it doesn't taste good.
- Honestly, I only know how to use pork.
I don't even know how to use chicken.
- Next, I'm gonna making a dough.
Only flour and raise warm water.
You know, people can use
the hot water, cold water.
Me prefer the warm water,
that way the though is soft,
and not too soft and not too hard
is perfect condition.
I think,
okay now.
So far, now I like it to
sleep like 20 minutes.
But normally like two hours,
three hours is better.
Cover it tight.
Don't let moisture, go out.
- So much mess, what the heck?
You work all day and
you come home do this?
Forget it. (laughing)
- Morning time, you just use
the store bought wrapper.
- Okay, next step.
I'm gonna put the cooking
wine into the meat,
soy sauce, this is my special one,
low salt, but more tasty.
Look good, too.
Little bit salt.
This called massage the lamb..
Then next step, make
this, it's spicy water.
So this water can kill the fishy smell.
I call the fishy smell.
Now is the fun part.
You know, you gotta do the
clockwise or counter clockwise.
One direction, you don't mix it.
You don't like do this one, this one,
you don't do that.
Then when I was kid, I see
my mom do this all time.
And I try to help.
I try to do the different way.
My mom said, no, no, you cannot do that.
I said, why?
You mess up the lamb!
No, not tasty.
Why? I don't ask me
why too many questions.
It's just not good.
Okay. I said, okay. (beep)
I just watch and eat.
This is the exercise too, work out.
You know, this meat the perfect time.
Not too much watery and not dry.
That's the perfect.
Now I'll mix the onion,
I like red onion better.
White onion a little sweet,
but red onion is spicy.
- That's a lot of onion.
- And it has a lot of water too.
And then she already dumped the water in.
- And the cucumber.
Cucumber make the
dumpling like fresh smell
Sesame oil, a little bit.
This is olive oil.
They can lock the water
of the vegetables inside.
That's all for the meat.
Now I'm taking out of
the top, make the skin.
Oh, well you're good.
Got to use one thumb into press,
and then one hand, you
know, roll it like this.
After you do the dumpling,
your thumb, you know
you'll be sore.
Then you make a hole inside
and you just do like this.
I see lot of people cut it little pieces.
I prefer like use my hand.
Like a piece of art.
It's fun.
I enjoy it.
Now I put a little dry flour on the top.
So when you make the skin, it
doesn't stick on the board.
Huh? I use the stick to make the skin.
- She does it so professionally.
Wow. Looks so thin, too.
- See the way you go to roll this out.
This all very fast.
Otherwise too much here until last there
the center is a little hard.
You don't go all the through,
otherwise the dumpling will burst.
Finished!
Filling in,
when I was kid, I told you
my grandma make the dumpling like this.
I said, mom, grandma look like a bug.
I don't want to eat it.
She said, you gotta eat it.
After I cook it,
you'll feel the bug delicious.
Look, pretty or not?
Now's the steam dumpling time.
Okay, that's enough.
Put on the top.
You'll count 13 minutes
and meantime I can make garlic sauce.
First of all, put a
garlic and then soy sauce.
Okay, and then sesame oil and then mix it.
Okay, let's check out the product.
Who want try it?
(upbeat music)
- Hi, my name is Susana Tan
and I'm from Hong Kong.
- Today I will be making
truffle dumplings.
- Do you know how to spell truffle?
- It's kind of expensive, no?
- Okay, first of all,
I have half a pound of pork here
and I have a piece of ginger
and I'm going to add some water to it.
So I let this sit,
while I put the rest of
the ingredients in it.
So I have a teaspoon of oyster sauce,
a teaspoon of soy sauce,
and a pinch of pepper.
And then I will add some truffle salt.
- What is that?
- Maybe MSG?
- Oh, don't put MSG, don't put that!
- Truffle pate, you can add
as much as you can, honestly.
And the truffle oil,
I'm going to strain the ginger water.
And now I'm gonna mix it all together.
I just loosen it up in the liquid
until I get the consistency that I want.
I do not knead it,
because personally if I knead it,
I find that feeling
becomes very thick and hard
after you cook them.
And now I will just add the chives.
I do not use a lot of chives
because chives has its
distinctive taste to it.
And because this is a truffle dumpling,
you do not want the chives to cover
the taste of the truffle.
Yeah.
Voila!
So now I'm going to wrap it.
I cannot fold it like how
other people can really fast.
I am pretty slow in doing this,
but patient pays, worth the wait.
I like to make eight folds on my dumpling
because eight is very
auspicious for the Chinese.
Eight means prosperity.
And when you make the dumplings,
it's supposed to be in the shape
of a Chinese golden nugget,
just like this.
Like a half moon so that's how it is.
I'm all ready to fry them.
I'll add a little oil,
just a little bit first.
It's not hot yet so we
can just swirl it around
so that the bottom has a bit of oil.
Arrange it nicely,
but make sure that it's
not touching each other.
Okay, now that it's a little
bit sizzling, not a lot,
I can add the water to it around the side.
You can hear it sizzles a little bit
and I'm going to cover it
with the water, like steaming,
like half steaming, half boiling.
- Fry's most delicious.
But fry,
you gotta have a very good skills.
- Okay, now that you see the
water has evaporated a lot,
you can add the oil so that
we are gonna fry the bottom
of it so it becomes crispy.
Okay. Sounds very good.
It looks pretty much done.
Let's see how crispy looks.
It's golden brown.
Mm. It smells good. It's gotta taste good.
And that's it. Here it is.
(upbeat music)
- Party time girl.
- Yeah.
- It's dumplings.
- Let me try Lily, yours first.
- Right.
- First.
- Okay.
- Oh, so good
- Girl.
- So juicy.
- Can I try yours?
- Yes, of course.
Please, please, please, please.
Well?
- You use very expensive oil.
(laughing)
- Okay. I'll try yours, Ping.
- Good?
Tell me the truth.
- First time I have lamb.
- In your whole life?
- In my whole life.
- I'm so proud.
- First time.
- It is so good.
- And why, why your girls
don't make the dough?
- Honestly, I don't
know how to make dough.
- Oh, how about you?
- I know how to do it.
- You just don't wanna do it.
- Yeah, because it's too much work.
(laughing)
- Lazy, lazy girls.
- The dough tastes good
if you made your own.
- Right?
- Different taste.
- Yeah. It tastes different.
- It's not only the lamb.
I think it's the soul.
My soul.
- Okay.
- My soul.
- She got dancing dumpling.
- What is that crunchy thing in it?
- You got almond?
- Oh I see!
- You the lucky one!
- Thanks for watching!
(upbeat music)